bonjour à vous tarek on en sait plus ce
matin sur l arrivée des civils de
marioupol
tout à fait ce convoi humanitaire qui
transportent les civils sortie de
l'usiné d'azf talent n'est toujours pas
arrivé ici à zaporijia au niveau de ce
parking d'un centre commercial nous
trouvons un parking qui a été transformé
en centre d'accueil ce convoi
humanitaire était censé arriver hier en
début d'après-midi alors il est toujours
extrêmement difficile d'obtenir la
moindre information sur ce convoi
humanitaire nous avons pu ce matin nous
entretenir avec l'un des coordinateurs
de l'onu en charge de ces opérations là
il a refusé de nous donner des détails
supplémentaires sur les raisons qui
seraient derrière le retard de l'arrivée
du convoi il avisé de nous donner le
nombre de personnes exact mais ce que
l'on sait c'est qu'il s'agirait
uniquement de femmes et d'enfants ou de
jeunes qui ont moins de 18 ans donc il
n'y aura ni homme ni soldats à bord de
ce convoi
il nous a également dit que ce convoi
arrivera dans les heures qui viennent et
selon lui avant l'heure du déjeuner
alors une fois arrivés sur place tous
ses citoyens de marioupol seront
enregistrées ici et seront transférés
dans une de ses tantes ou les attentes
des organisations humanitaires qu'elle
soit locale ou internationale on leur
donna de quoi boire et manger on leur
donna des vêtements il ya également
beaucoup de psychologues sur place
beaucoup de psychologues justement pour
apporter tout le soutien nécessaire pour
ces citoyens qui ont passé près de deux
mois dans des conditions extrêmement
difficiles tarek caille envoyé spécial
de france 24 à sa peau rides jade